this is Startalk could you actually
create a black hole on earth you
wouldn't want to okay but you could you
know you could oh yeah okay yeah yeah
and in a lab I mean in principle you can
create a region of matter so dense and
small that it would classify as a black
hole what happens as small black holes
evaporate according to Hawking radiation
the small ones evaporate way faster than
big ones so if you make a tiny mini
microscopic black hole it would have it
might evaporate before it has a chance
to eat the earth gotcha you what we
don't want to find that that's right
yeah as some we don't have my favorite
line I'm told it was from a I don't
remember this line but people tell me
from a Kurt Vonnegut novel he he
hypothesized what the very last sentence
ever spoken by humanity was and LEM was
hey was let's try it this way
it's two scientists having a
conversation let's try it this with it
oh I love it
all right yeah okay well hey thanks
Jared
[Music]